This team knows that being a champ is about more than trophies and rings.
It's about being a winner off the court as well as on it.
And giving back to those who are less fortunate.
The Lakers and the NBA have always been about serving others.
Earlier today, the team joined with our United We Serve Initiative...
...to hold a fitness clinic for kids from Stanton Elementary School right here in Washington, D.C.
Teaching them a few moves, but also how to live healthy and active lives.
We had a practice and we let them come in and watch some of our practice.
Our warm-ups and some of the things we're doing.
And we kind of opened up the court and let the kids come down on the court.
They did what we would do in clinics,...
...you know, dribbling, speed drill, and relay drill.
You know, we enjoy seeing their smiles and in turn it makes us happy,...
...so it's a good opportunity for us to bond with the kids.
We're trying to give them great experiences and open their eyes...
...because if you do that, those same kids will start dreaming...
...that one day they could become a President Obama or a Kobe Bryant.
President Obama accomplished something that many people thought was impossible,...
...and to be able to shake his hand and look him in the eye is truly an inspiration.
Now we got to turn our ears on and our mind...
...because of the very important message that comes at the end of this, alright?
I'm talking to you about doing good in school and getting good grades...
...and doing all of those things, but you have to have the energy to do that.
And the energy comes from eating right, getting your rest in the mornings,...
...but also trying to have some fun like this at least once a day.
We're just trying to make sure you understand though the importance of just being active.
Especially in this day and age, I know childhood obesity is a big issue.
I'm just trying to get kids fit and active and thinking about eating right...
...and getting enough rest and doing the right thing.
It's important so we have a little bit of time to do that today,...
...and I think it worked out well for both sides.
Lakers!